hello and good morning thanks for being
with us world leaders are paying tribute
to mikhail gorbachev who died last night
at the age of 91. president joe biden
says that gorbachev created freedom for
millions of people while boris johnson
has praised his courage and integrity
president vladimir putin offered only
condolences underscoring the mixed
legacy of a man credited with ending the
cold war but who oversaw the collapse of
the soviet union diana magna reports now
from moscow
mikhail gorbachev came to power at a
time when the ussr was seen as the evil
empire locked in a nuclear arms race
with the united states
under his leadership the cold war would
finally come to an end but the soviet
union would collapse
he was a new kind of soviet leader able
to engage easily with his people a man
western leaders could do business with
but he inherited a superpower with a
failing economy which he knew could no
longer afford the cold war
in the white house he found a president
equally interested in reducing nuclear
weapons their signature agreement to ban
short and medium-range ballistic
missiles halting the nuclear arms race
my semester general secretary though my
pronunciation may give you difficulty
the maxim is dovahyai no proverbiai
trust but verify
restructuring
as the berlin wall came down he refused
to intervene even as the communist
regimes of eastern europe collapsed he
was awarded the nobel peace prize the
following year
but not everyone was celebrating
conservative hardliners attempted a coup
d'etat the people under boris yeltsin
pushed back
after three days the coup collapsed but
the balance of power had shifted away
from gorbachev and on christmas day 1991
he had no choice but to resign
the soviet union was no more but it
would usher in a decade of chaos which
many in russia would blame him
remained critical of his successes in
the kremlin and especially of vladimir
putin a man whose long decades in power
saw the freedoms which gorbachev had won
for his people crushed
the russian president has expressed his
deepest condolences
u.s president joe biden calling
gorbachev's reforms the acts of a rare
leader one with the imagination to see
that a different future was possible and
the courage to risk his entire career to
achieve it
all right let's cross now live to moscow
where we can bring in diana magnay whose
report you just saw diana good morning
to you so how is this news being
received in moscow
well
it happened uh late last night so i
don't think this is the last that we'll
hear from vladimir putin who's expressed
his condolences and who said that he
will send a telegram to his family today
i think it is hard to over overstate the
legacy of the man the impact he had on
20th century politics and if you think
about it he is the last of that
generation of world leaders after helmut
cole and george bush senior to pass away
all of whom had real respect for each
other's values for each other's
desire for uh peaceful ways of achieving
a new post-soviet world order but i
think that his legacy is extremely
conflicted and there are many people in
this country who will resent the way
that he is celebrated abroad who during
his time in office felt that he wasn't
pushing through his reforms far enough
others who blame him for the collapse of
the soviet union and the chaos which
this country went through in the 1990s
and i think you will feel a lot of that
sentiment coming out in the next few
days
he will be buried in three days time a
family burial we're hearing where he'll
be laid to rest next to his beloved wife
raisa who died in 1999
and he has had a long time without her a
woman he really looked to for his
counsel for his everything
and i think in these last few years and
especially in these last few six months
it must have been profoundly disturbing
for uh michael gorbachev to look at the
kind of russia um that vladimir putin
had turned his country into
okay diana for now in moscow i
appreciate that thank you
i'll just go to ukraine now where a
convoy of nuclear inspectors has set off
for the plant that's controlled by
russian forces and has been since the
early days of the invasion of ukraine
let's bring in our security defense
editor deborah haynes who is in the city
of cleveland good morning to you so uh
just bring us up to speed where we are
with this convoy of of um inspectors
where they're going and what their plans
are
so they set off from kiev this morning
they're heading for uh the city of
zappos the region of zaparisia and from
there they're going to be accessing this
nuclear plant which has been under
russian control since march and there
have been growing concerns that clashes
around the area could damage the plant
and trigger some kind of nuclear
catastrophe the head of the iaea who is
actually part of the mission says that
they're going to be spending a number of
days at the site they want to assess the
situation get a sense of of how serious
it is in terms of the safety concerns
and then establish a permanent presence
there he's very clear this is a war zone
they're entering into they need
guarantees from both sides that their
team and himself will be protected he
says he's got that and the mission is
underway and at the same time here in
ukraine we have the third day now of a
major counter-offensive by ukrainian
forces against russian troops into
russian held territory the uk defense
ministry is saying that ukraine has has
made has gone some distance in places
into russia-controlled territory we've
not been able to have access ourselves
um but we've seen a lot of images on
social media showing this the the the
explosions from the ukrainian offensive
okay deborah for now in our crib speech
again thank you all right now the u.s
department of justice says that there
were efforts to obstruct its
investigation into the discovery of
classified documents at donald trump's
house in florida
the doj has released this image showing
documents marked top secrets on a carpet
at mar-a-lago the department of justice
added that records were lightly
concealed and removed from a storage
room even after the former president's
representatives had assured officials
that they'd thoroughly searched the
property the fbi also sees 33 boxes
containing more than 100 classified
records during its search earlier this
month and found three classified
documents stashed in draws
more on that story throughout the day
now there's a fresh cost of living
squeeze today with the war in ukraine
being blamed for a surge in prices at
shops and supermarkets around the
country the british retail consortium
says that shop price annual inflation
accelerated to 5.1 in august up from a
four and a half percent the month before
that's the biggest jump it's ever
recorded now the biggest driver of these
prices is fresh food which is up 10.5
percent
the rise in shop and supermarket costs
is contributing to wider inflation
across the country which some analysts
predict could top 18 percent
next year
well let's bring in emma birchley is at
new common garden market in south london
emma good morning to you so you've got a
nice bag of onions there next to you but
how much more are these things going to
be costing people
they're going to be costing people so
much more and actually you don't need
statistics and reports to tell you what
we're all feeling every day and that is
that when you go and buy your food it
costs much more than it used to here you
couldn't get food much fresher it's
going to schools it's going to
restaurants pubs hospitality industry
but come a look right onions
up 10
warren ukraine is obviously an issue but
here in this country it's um droughts
it's the heat wave new crop potatoes
they're much smaller this year they are
up 40 in price but come along here and
look at the watermelon so normally
these would cost nature's choice which
is where we are today about two pounds
they are now costing them five pounds
and that obviously all gets passed on so
when it comes to stuff in this country
we're talking about
the heat the lack of rain
but of course the war in ukraine is
having a major impact when it comes to
things like watermelons mangoes are the
same
they're having to be flown in to be at
their absolute best quality and the the
air fuel costs are so high and that is
partly why we are feeling this real
pinch and why everything is costing us
so much more
i know do appreciate that thank you
all right let's bring in the housing
minister now uh for what the government
is going to be doing about this cost
living crisis on please say we're joined
by marcus jones michael jones good
morning to you so we've seen
the british retail consortium saying
that uh prices are going up in the shops
we know that inflation is likely to top
at least 12 next year i mean what is the
government going to be doing to make
sure that people can get through this
crisis they're facing for the next few
months
well it's a hugely challenging time for
people and i don't underestimate how
difficult it is i can see that in my own
constituency
in an eaton where local people are
struggling with the cost of living and
where many businesses are also being
affected particularly by the war in
ukraine and energy prices and the main
thing that the government's done so far
is to provide a 37 billion pound package
of support for people that's 1200 pounds
to the lowest paid families and they'll
be receiving that from now across into
the autumn
then pensioners will be receiving
850 pounds
in support and every household will
receive 400 pounds uh in support
during this package that we have in the
autumn but i have absolutely no doubt
that there is more to be done uh people
are finding things very very difficult
and i know that both contenders in the
leadership contest are going to have a
new uh prime minister next week both of
those candidates have talked extensively
about the cost of living
and i know
that that will be number one in terms of
their priorities when they take office
and certainly i know once we get back to
parliament next week uh it will be a
discussion uh that is being had
constantly because people across the
country will know
from being constituency mps at what a
challenging time this is for the people
they represent yes you accept that the
package put forward by the person you're
supporting uh in his previous job for
leadership which is sunak is inadequate
so more will need to be done what about
the idea of freezing prices at this
point you've seen that there is growing
support you've seen the front pages some
of the newspapers this morning huge
support for that idea across the country
to freeze prices right now
well this has been a very fast-moving
situation clearly the energy price cap
has now been announced uh to come into
effect uh during the autumn clearly
we've then got further announcements
that are likely to be made
in january um the support given is
significant it's 37 billion pounds that
is a huge amount of money but clearly
gonna be uh that's going to be
adequately don't worry mr jones we know
well
i've already
said
and we've known for some some weeks that
that's going to be inadequate
why there's not more coming now i've
already made it very clear kamali that
more needs to be done
uh i think it's important that the
current prime minister has given the
opportunity to the new prime minister to
look at the situation and to make
decisions accordingly uh from the
beginning of next week but absolutely
i'm in no doubt that more will need to
be done to help people
as for freezing um the price of energy
clearly that's been suggested and
clearly uh i'm sure i can understand why
people are drawn to that but clearly
we're dealing with a worldwide energy
price here and if anything is done it's
clearly the taxpayer uh together with
urban pages and clearly we've put the
levy uh currently uh on energy companies
but clearly a package of methods is
required uh and targeted support is
needed for those who need it both
yeah i mean it doesn't sound like you're
saying necessarily you're against the
idea of freezing prices there
well i i'm in favor of uh bringing
measures forward that are going to help
people particularly targeted measures
and very much the package that's already
been put forward the most vulnerable in
society will
have 1200 pounds
basically towards their energy costs if
they've got symbol disabled in the
family that will be
1350 pounds and the announcement i came
on to make today was about
capping social rents so that 1.7 million
of
people that don't get any help with
their housing costs
from the taxpayer that they will have
protection on their social rents so that
their uh rent bill will be 300 pounds
less than it would have been next year
yeah and that 300 pounds of course will
be very very valuable to to lots of
people but as you said it's next year
there's a consultation that has to go
through the process now
you know 300 pounds off their rent over
the year coming next year is not going
to help anyone whose bill's going up on
the 1st of october
well clearly it's important that we give
people certainty we give them
reassurance and that's what we've got to
do going forward with any further
package i think people will be
reassured more when they start to
receive the 37 billion pounds that's
coming out some of that has already
started to be received by families but
the line share of that is going out
across
the
autumn months
the electricity companies this month are
starting
to
knock the amount of money that we're
providing off people's electricity bills
and for those on pre-payment meters
they will have an amount credited each
month
to make up that 400 pounds we're
providing but i'm under no illusion
whatsoever that more will need to be
done and
i'm looking forward to the new prime
minister coming in next week and i'm
sure the new prime minister whether that
is rishi or it's this
will be very aware of the difficulties
that people are going through and we'll
start to set out how they're going to
help people across this very very tough
period now this this cap on on rental
prices this will affect people in social
housing it'll affect housing association
tenants as well won't it
it will it will support housing
association tenants as well there's
about four million people
uh or four million households that this
will help
but particularly those 1.7 million of
those households where those households
do not claim any form of housing
benefits
and therefore they will find that next
year rather than the situation that they
were likely to face which was an 11 hike
in their
in their cost of their rent next year
we're looking at
restricting that to five percent trying
to get the balance between
the tenants who need support with the
cost of living
and housing associations and local
authorities and we expect to continue to
make repairs and improvements to
property and build new social housing uh
so that we have more social housing
staff for people to live in yeah
absolutely right which is what people
want to see but this policy uh when i
read it this morning i was very
interested because it sounded sounded
quite familiar to me and it's very
similar to what the labour party under
jeremy corbyn proposed in 2019 on
putting a cap on prices there it is in
the labor manifesto rent cap labels stop
runaway rents by capping them with
inflation giving cities power to cap
rent further 2019 jeremy corbyn
manifesto pledge and now it's being
recycled by you guys
well this is very different because this
is about social rents this is about
properties that have received
significant taxpayer funding uh to
originally uh build uh
policy covered that as well didn't it
marcus
it did cover that and you may recall
kamali
the the preview a previous conservative
government between
2015 and 2020 did a similar thing before
jeremy corbyn came out with his
announcement but i think what jeremy
corbyn was aiming at was a rent cap in
the private rented sector
which would be
disastrous for people because it's
likely to lead to a massive reduction in
the amount of homes available for social
rent and leave many many people out of
the home uh who are not uh in a position
uh to purchase a home uh using a
mortgage
i mean what pushback do you expect to
get on this from um local councils and
i think more specifically housing
association that they're you know
they're privately run businesses
well i've had a number of private
conversations uh on this issue uh with
housing providers in the social sector
since i took this role on in july uh i
think they recognize the difficulties
that are out there for their tenants and
clearly they want to make sure that
their rents are still
being paid
they also want any sort any policy
that's brought forward to be balanced in
the context of being able to still make
repairs
to properties and still being able to
develop new properties
i'm not saying this
policy
will leave them jumping for joy but i
think it strikes the right balance and i
think many social housing providers will
understand
why the government are proposing the
action that we are
yeah well hopefully uh for your for your
sake they will understand just the final
uh question into your marcus jones um
boris johnson yesterday didn't rule out
trying to make a comeback i mean how
useful is that after all this time
months of this leadership contest and
the the fractures it's brought to your
party for mr johnson to still be saying
he might well come back in the future
and try and lead again
well i think it's important now that we
focus on the future clearly
boris
of his own volition decided to resign as
a leader of the party for the reasons uh
that we all know
clearly we're going through a leadership
contest which concludes at the beginning
of next week that's my focus
we should now get behind whoever the
leader is whether that is rishi or liz
come next monday it's behold on the
whole of the conservative parliamentary
party to do that because we must focus
on the big issues that affect the people
and the big issues that the people are
just expecting answers on
so i don't think we should keep dwelling
uh on this type of question it is a
hypothetical question and i think we
will need to see how boris reacts uh to
not being the prime minister clearly
different ex-prime ministers have
reacted in different ways david cameron
stepped down in 2016 and clearly theresa
may's carried on after 2019 and made a
significant contribution in parliament
so i think we should see how that plays
out but my focus is absolutely on who
the new leader is likely to be and
supporting that leader come what may to
make sure that we are delivering for the
people in what is a very very difficult
critical time for the country
so okay marcus jones minister for
housing do appreciate your time this
morning thanks for being here thank you
all right let me bring you a little bit
of breaking news that's coming into us
here at sky uh
british staff at nine train operators as
well as train infrastructure owner
network network rail are going to walk
out on a 24-hour strike beginning on the
26th of september this is over pay in
conditions the transport salaried staffs
association said it will still be in
talks with network rail about a possible
settlement
all right let's bring in our political
correspondent amanda akas who is with us
now live good morning to you amanda so
um you know we've got more worrying news
coming from the british retail
consortium and also there uh marcus
jones saying that the government was
going to do more eventually
yes i mean he said he was no doubt that
more needs to be done um and also said
that the cost of living crisis is the
number one priority for both candidates
in the conservative leader leadership
race as well of course it is really i
mean the prime minister himself boris
johnson yesterday who is still of course
in power until tuesday um also
reiterated this message that further
support would be coming down the line
from both candidates we know that civil
servants in the treasury for example are
working on potential different options
depending on what the winner of the
contest decides to do but fundamentally
there's still no real detail on those
options what they are looking at which
now that we do know what the energy
price cap increase is going to be we
found out on friday it'll be going up to
three and a half thousand pounds in
october from just under 2 000 pounds at
present we've heard those figures from
the british retail consortium showing
how quickly food prices are going up too
people are trying to budget for the
winter and there is a growing clamour
for more detail to be released quickly
we know that liz trust for example she's
pledging to cut the
increase in national insurance so we've
seen and pause green levies on energy
bills mr sunak saying that he wants to
see targeted support uh going to the
most vulnerable pensioners and those on
lowest incomes but it does indeed look
like we're going to have to wait until
tuesday when we find out who the next
prime minister is before we really have
any more detail on that we'll all keep
waiting amanda for now appreciate that
thank you
all right let's take a look at the
morning's front pages now and many of
them have pictures of mikhail gorbachev
on the front page it's the front page of
the guardians you can see there
paying tributes to mr gorbachev and also
the main story on the garden guardian
there is
fears that food banks are about to run
out of stock
the times front page two has gorbachev
their main story is about a plan to use
the nhs app to allow patients to see
where in the country has the shortest
waiting times for their particular
treatment
the eye leads with calls from small
businesses for liz trust to save them
from a 400 percent
energy price hike if she were to become
prime minister next week
financial times has an interview with
rishi sunak warning about the dangers of
financial markets losing confidence in
the uk if trust wins and implements her
suggested policies of tax cuts
while the sun reports on meghan markle's
comments about people comparing her
to nelson mandela
all right some of your mornings other
headlines now
and centrica the company which owns
british gas has been given permission to
reopen its gas storage facility in the
north sea the facility in question once
provided about 70 of the uk's gas
storage capacity the supplier says it's
prepared to spend the two billion pounds
needed to make the site operational
again it was closed four years ago
now people with a hard to treat superbug
that affects the gut known as clostrium
difficile are to be offered
fecal transplants to tackle their
infections the national institute for
health and care excellence says that gut
bacteria taken from a healthy person's
poo can restore healthy function it can
be taken orally in a capsule
now nasa says it will make a second
attempt today debut launch of its rocket
on it saturday five days after technical
issues forced it to abort its initial
attempt there it is on the launch pad
but there are concerns about what the
weather has in store for the next few
days in florida nasa's weather officer
says they see a 60
no-go chance for saturday
good if we got up wonder now
a new report has found that the cost of
food is rising at its fastest rate in
more than a decade that's according to
the british retail consortium as
whatever was telling us about earlier
from common garden market they saw that
shops rose by 5.1 percent in august but
food price increased by 9.3 percent well
let's bring in uh
the external affairs advisor for the
british retail consortium emma revel
emma revel good morning to you so just
take us through some of these figures
why are we seeing these numbers go up so
quickly
so as you said general shock prices uh
increased 5.1 in the three months to
august but for food that's 9.3 and
that's been driven primarily by the war
in ukraine it's a combination of
increased
grain costs and also demand
and difficulties getting vegetable oil
out of the country which
means the
products that use quite vegetable oil
quite intensively such as crisps
and butter and things like milk are
rising in price because the cost of
grain and therefore animal feed is
increasing meaning it's costing farmers
more to to keep and feed the animals
which then obviously leads to the cost
of things like milk and eggs increase
now of course the war in ukraine is is
going to be ongoing it's got no ends in
sight so what can be done to try and
bring food prices down in the short term
well retailers are doing everything they
can to try and absorb as much of the
cost as possible by expanding their
value ranges and freezing prices on
essential goods but there's only so much
that retailers can do so you know our
biggest ask of the new government is to
address the business rates burden it's
an enormous uh tax on on retail um and
even just inflation is likely to add
three billion pounds to the bill for the
next year so we're asking the government
to address that to unlock um additional
investment if that money isn't being
spent on business rates retailers are
able to absorb more of the costs and
invest in you know the efficiency and
the productivity of their businesses and
their workforce and are you hearing that
that might be a possibility from one of
the candidates
um they've both signaled a willingness
to you know bring the tax burden down
and to look at you know
um business taxes so you know we are we
are hopeful but it is sort of a critical
um thing that we need to see address
along with the cost of energy which not
only affects you know uh viewers in
their houses but you know factories
shops uh the whole supply chain in
retail is affected by that as well
i mean uh retailers that you speak to do
they feel like they've been sort of let
down or left to just wait in
anticipation like the rest of us for
some kind of plan to help them get
through this cost of living crisis
well what retails are doing is is being
quite proactive they recognize obviously
that the essential goods um
are essential for a reason and that it's
important to do everything they can to
freeze those prices and to expand those
ranges with a time when people are
struggling so retailers are doing
everything they can they just want to
see you know government support
alongside that to help them with their
investment
okay emma revel from the british retail
consortium appreciate your time this
morning thank you for being with us
now if you can scan that qr code on your
screen right now because you've got your
phone in your hand you can listen to the
latest edition of the sky news daily
today
with the price of energy biting neil
patterson speaks to the forgotten
businesses in the crisis and asks what
the future holds for employers you can
subscribe to the daily for free wherever
you get your podcasts
all right time now for a look at what
the weather has in store
warm memories wherever you go
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
now the weather uh looks to be fairly
settled for the next few days but things
will turn wet and windy at the weekend
now at the moment most places are
looking fine and dry and there is some
good sunshine around it's chilly in
northeast scotland world around southern
coasts there's quite a keen wind we're
seeing more cloud in the east and this
is giving some light showers
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
now stars from the world of music and
film are coming together to celebrate
the life of the late entrepreneur jamal
edwards including
now as you probably know ed sheeran and
jamal has worked together in ed's early
careers counted as one of jamal's
biggest success stories now mr sheeran
idris albert jesse ware and others will
gather at the first fundraising event
for the jamal edwards trust next month
all the money raised at the gala will go
towards supporting young people who are
looking to thrive in the media industry
all right it's a good cause now let's
take a look at some of the morning's
best picture stories from this morning's
newspapers and there you go played a few
games like that myself that is a wet
football match in gloucestershire uh it
didn't put them off he's wearing running
shoes not great for grip now the two
teams took part in the annual football
match in the river in burton on the
water it certainly was on the water uh
it finished uh neil nil i'm not sure how
in wales the annual bog snorkling
competition has been taking place yes
people snorkel in bogs because
why not
competitors aim to complete two lengths
of a 55 meter water filled trench cut
through the peat bog in the shortest
time possible and to make it
more difficult and more interesting they
wear fancy dresses you can see there was
a shark there santas and various
different
fish well done to all of you guys and
finally the duke and duchess of
cambridge have been invited to meet
their lego doppelgangers to celebrate
their move to windsor there is a lego
mock-up of the moving van that is
excellent william kate prince george
princess charlotte and prince louis and
dog owler will be displayed and packing
their lego brick furniture that is great
my son loved that
hello and welcome back to pakistan now
where devastating flooding has killed
more than a thousand people
the united nations has launched an
appeal for emergency aid a third of
pakistan is said to be underwater with
the south
and uh center central parts of the
country worst affected
now the province of sindh has had nearly
six times as much rain as it would
normally get in an average monsoon
season 47 million people lived there but
only a tiny fraction have received eight
just one hundred thousand tents fifty
thousand food packs and around two
thousand hygiene kits sky's shining
motion reports from dardu
there were homes here once
children playing
and a community
now everything is submerged in a
never-ending vista of water
the people of umri now perched carefully
on a muddy mound they've been forced to
call home
a third of pakistan is now underwater in
a country this big that's difficult to
comprehend
an estimated 33 million people affected
and the country is struggling to keep up
with need for aid with the navy and army
drafted into help
pakistani officials are unequivocal they
believe this is a very real consequence
of climate change its citizens have been
experiencing extreme weather conditions
that have come together in an
extraordinary nexus starting with a heat
wave that saw temperatures right here in
sindh province reaching 53 degrees and
in the north of the country those
soaring temperatures
caused the glaciers to melt sending
water gushing down into pakistan's major
rivers and then we are now in the midst
of a monster monsoon
this is not a river that has broken its
banks it's rainfall settling on dry
ground
here on the outskirts of dadu
the families told us of their escape and
anger at the lack of support
i've got little children
we just managed to save them but why
isn't anybody helping us
the landowners and authorities here
don't care about us
pakistan is amongst some of the lowest
contributors to greenhouse gas emissions
but its small carbon footprint will not
save it from global climate change
its people will be
and are amongst the worst affected
for now they have escaped the water
and build skeletal shelters to escape
the heat of the
sun to say we can go live to adado now
where simon is standing by for us good
morning to you uh sima so look just tell
us what's the situation like on the
ground right now
kamali we're really feeling uh the
effects of the extreme weather it's uh
since early morning here the
temperatures have been extremely high
which behind me you can probably see all
three reasons that i just explained in
my report for what is impacting pakistan
right now
extreme heat dry ground water absolutely
everywhere as we've driven
to mali i have seen hundreds and
hundreds of people on the sides of roads
they if you can see just behind me over
my left shoulder here there's people
have created temporary homes using
sticks and pieces of cloth some of them
have taken off their their scarves to to
use that as some form of protection from
either the heat or the rain what little
protection that will offer them we
haven't actually found many aid drops in
this particular area i know that
pakistani forces have made an
international appeal of course because
they are struggling to reach the
capacity and resources that they need
for the 33 million people affected
now i appreciate that
now let's bring in pakistan's climate
change minister that is uh miss shetty
rahman who is in islamabad for us this
morning ms rahman good to have you with
us and and thank you for joining us um
just tell us what is the situation like
um for the recovery effort in the
affected areas right now well thank you
very much for that excellent report from
dadu uh your reporter at least was
sensitive to conditions on the ground
as you can see they're absolutely
disastrous
we are in the middle of a converging of
multiple uh climate uh impacts and it's
a perfect storm if you like and so the
relief efforts to service frankly more
than 33 million people uh that have been
assessed
is gargantuan we are um stretched to the
maximum
people not just uh our military but our
civilians are pitching in now because
food packs basic hygiene uh
you know items and then obviously the
shelters even the the tents are not
enough
for the first two weeks our helicopters
were not able to do the normal relief
and rescue and evacuations because they
could not get off the ground and the
navy had to be employed it's been
absolutely unprecedented uh and
relentless even today from seven percent
uh seven hundred percent
uh the rainfall is at 500 percent the
temperatures are too high otherwise and
53 degrees is uninhabitable uh for the
summer we never had a spring
and it is becoming a challenge that is
of epic proportions we are very clear
there is at this point we are at maximum
overstretch
yeah and you say maximum maximum and
overstretched so that begs the question
is is the government up to dealing with
this what assistance does pakistan need
from the international community
yes we have asked of course i don't
think any particular government in this
collapsed uh time in the telescope time
we have available to reach our people
not just to provide them really but
actually rescue them from different sets
of uh
districts where uh you know multiple
kinds of storms are hitting them the
north is is very different the cascades
there race down the water may be less
here the water is just sitting on the
ground because in the flat most of
balochistan is flat so yes we require a
great deal of
actually
urgent cash assistance because the cash
grants are going out and i was just
speaking to the bisp minister wheels the
been a zero income support program will
soon be running out of
urgent resources to transfer to very to
the most vulnerable families and that's
uh
it's a huge amount it's 35 billion right
now it is on its way
but at the same time food is needed on
the ground cooked food shelter hygiene
kits now even doctors and medical camps
because
many are in will be in need of medical
care there is a threat of epidemics
waterborne diseases because as we know
there are there's a lot of there's a the
mosquito cover is getting very dense
especially in the night there's a dengue
scare and many other waterborne diseases
especially diarrhea for the children and
the women
so uh we have
one third of pakistan is underwater how
do we service the relief rescue even
find dry ground in parts of sin there
wasn't dry ground until today i mean
it's mostly today even the uh the famous
highway on both sides of the indus on
the middle of the indus that huge artery
has been inundated it's it's
it's not a river bursting banks it is
just the water falling down
and
more rain expected to come as well
come again
i'm asking if the forecast is showing
that there is more rain due for the
region
heard that uh the met office tells us
that mid-september we need to brace for
more but i mean really what do we do how
many shelters are we going to rebuild
and how many people can be relocated to
dry land we have a very large population
and out of 160 districts which includes
ajk and
pakistan
110 districts have been actually
affected and 72
declared calamity hit so that's more
than one third of pakistan that's really
frankly it's more than half
so how are we going to service this we
are running a war room and that's why i
haven't been able to leave isla but
except for sporadic uh trips down south
and north but you'd be running a war
room here
we're needing to run more than one
because 24 7
we are still unable to meet the services
and dire
survival needs of people on the front
lines of what really is a climate
catastrophe and the climate catastrophe
of the decade quite honestly
yeah and
on the funding amounts the uk government
says up to 1.5 million pounds uh will be
sent to help with the flood relief is
that enough
well that's frankly that's very kind but
it's uh it's mostly our repurposed
development loans uh i do believe
they're working on more that's that's a
drop in the ocean we appreciate every
drop because the drops pile up but right
now in an emergency we're not sneezing
at any any assistance we appreciate the
the the spirit behind it but we really
need a lot more i mean just the relief
efforts uh we were doing back of the
envelopes and now it's really real uh
calculations the finance minister and i
were calculating just the relief efforts
just the basic cash transfers
first round of relief efforts is going
to cost us one billion dollars um
then uh the
basic reconstruction not counting the
crop losses because since it's half the
bread basket of pakistan uh
is it's the crop is all gone uh and now
we're hearing reports of power looms
shutting down naturally because they're
they're inundated and people are losing
jobs so it's one of those you know
uh
multiple uh
impacts
coming together
to form a very uh very kind of critical
dynamic at this point and 10 billion
dollars which the which the finance
ministers calculated in my view will not
go beyond just basic uh rehabilitation
and some sectors of the economy
recovering this will not cover critical
climate rebuilding back climate
resilience uh uh you know infrastructure
because many of the bridges in hebrew
many of the highways and roads strong
metal roads uh have just been wiped out
many were built back better after 2010
super flood according to international
standards they've all been wiped out
because the speed scale and velocity
of the water either coming down or
coming down from the indus depending
which part of the country you're in
so it's really i mean today i see
563 kilometers of roads gone yesterday
the figure was uh you know less than
that and 243 bridges down
they are trying to rebuild some of them
but it's very hard with the torrential
rains as well as um you know the the
river indus now beginning its
traditional riverine outflow from the
north where the glaciers are melting
those torrents are very different from
the ones that we're seeing in sin and
the problems are also quite the it's a
big it's the biggest hydro med disaster
of of as in living memory that i've seen
and uh in you know i can recommend as
the climate minister or changing our
agriculture systems i can recommend it's
it's easy for me to advise uh that oh
you can um rebuild the entire irrigation
architecture to interrupt you but we we
have we have run short of time you have
made your point very forcefully and um
we hope that you get the funding that
you need to try and help those millions
tens of millions of people who are
affected thank you i'm sherry rahman the
minister for climate change for pakistan
thank you
all right let's get a little uh
look at the situation for humanitarian
organizations working on the ground i'm
pleased to say we're joined by alif
jabar khan who is a country director for
water in pakistan uh mr uh alif jabar um
just talk to us about the situation you
guys are finding yourselves in and the
work um that you're having to do
yeah well as our minister honourable
minister said i think it is gigantic
and even the relief effort is quite
difficult and not only now but i think
it has long-term implications for the
country because
uh you know
where uh your reporter simon was i
actually saw people i am hundred miles
south of where she is and people have
traveled all this distance from there in
search of relief goods in the city of
hyderabad and i'm sure it's happening in
other cities and what they are doing is
basically occupying whatever place they
can i just visited
you know a college uh where there were
800 people living
and it's only the philanthropy
you know philanthropic support they are
getting there and you know we are trying
to mobilize uh some response uh there
but i think the scale of the response is
is is much bigger than anyone can
imagine and i was you know as as
others have said i've i was
you know i was
uh here in the 2010 response as well and
there
it you know the water just came and flew
you know flew
it it went down and you know
we were able to plan accordingly now
what is happening is it started in the
first year the heat wave then the south
and the north and moorings coming in so
even the response efforts are being
hampered by the climatic climatic you
know the the weather conditions that we
are faced with right now
okay uh uh mr alif jabar khan sorry we
have one short time i do appreciate you
you being with us this morning and we
wish you all the very best of luck in
your work and in the recovery effort
thank you for now
thank you
all right let me just bring you a little
bit more on the second day of those
royal mail strikes as 115 000 workers
walk off the job we can uh speak now to
john carson who is a postman and
assistant secretary of the communication
workers union based in glasgow uh john
carson good to have you with us so um
the royal mail say they've offered you a
5.5 pay rise is that true
uh well i mean it's true that they have
offered or they've claimed to offer five
and a half percent but it's attached
with uh many many strings and there's a
number of hoops you'd have to jump
through to get there what they have done
so far is they have imposed two percent
uh pay rise on the workforce without
negotiation without agreement with the
the trade union the cwu and you know the
way things are with inflation that's not
going to pay our bills our members are
seriously struggling when it comes to
that you've got some members here
working 60 70 hours every single week
working six days a week some people are
working seven days a week and we can
survive on that two percent it's not
good enough especially when we look at
the hundreds of millions of pounds and
profit the companies have been making
and also the hundreds of thousands of
pounds has been paying out to ceos and
millions of pounds has been paying out
to his shareholders
yeah i mean is it a tough spot for
posters right now though because you
know the the company will say that they
want to see modernization which you know
means streamlining which may mean jobs
going if you want to get the pay for
some of your members that you think they
deserve
i mean
i have to say right away that
modernization has been an aspect of the
postal service for decades now you know
we have
seen a reduction in the workforce
because of mechanization and obviously
the union the workers have been working
with that you know day after day
delivery postal workers like myself
we've been dealing with change uh you
know on the streets every single day you
know you just have two deliveries now
you have one delivery we've been using
new technologies whether it's capturing
photo images of parcels and then when
you look at the mail center operation we
have massive machines monstrous machines
that deal with parcels so we've been
part of that process and we don't
disagree with that process but what the
union is saying very clearly we will not
accept this you accept pay which isn't
high enough or your terms and your
conditions and your jobs are going we
can't accept that we kind of live by
that we're not going to
that's not a trade-off that we want we
are saying the work that was done over
the work was done in the pandemic postal
workers absolutely deserve in those
things pay award because of that
especially when the money is going out
to those who are in charge of the film
yeah and of course the company will say
that you know they find it difficult to
to meet those demands so where does this
go from here then john i mean how much
more industrial action are we going to
see and how much more disruption are
customers going to see
well to be honest now that i think is
very much in royal mail's hands i mean
the union is open for further and
further talks the workforce here are
absolutely solid because at the end of
the day we just kind of live on what is
being offered or what has been imposed
so far and ultimately as well you know
we have an obligation of doing a service
and a deep connection with local
communities and one of the fundamental
questions about this is about whether
the work of a post-worker is to be
determined by the market or whether to
be determined by its social and its
community value so we want to be back
out in the streets we want to be out
working with our people you know as we
have all through the pandemic especially
the most vulnerable in our society we
want to be doing that job but ultimately
the decision is with royal mail who is
trying to drive this you know a market
agenda that is trying to undermine the
terms and conditions and the pay and
value of a postal worker where we know
that communities value those services
far more highly than that and that's why
we need to see everybody back around the
table so that we get a proper pay award
for everything that we have done
okay john carson uh from the cw in
glasgow thanks for your time thank you
thank you
oh well those strikes will go on now let
me just show you a bit of footage that
shows the huge amount of junk left
behind by people who went to reading
festival over the weekend every year
it's terrible but this looks
particularly bad maybe just those drone
shots now they've left tents
bottles sleeping bags everything it's
just
a mess now they show hundreds
of thousands of
abandoned attempts now police had to say
that they wanted people to try and clean
up this is kids who probably should know
better but there were they were called
the police were called after they were
burning of tents at this year's uh
reading festival the headliners of
course don't get done any of that and
the arctic monkeys played which was very
nice all right we'll have more
from
the show after the break